Another technique that uses a similar
idea to what we did when we increased
the block size to reduce the number
of misses, is called pre-fetching.
The way prefetching works is that we
guess which blocks will be accessed soon
in the future, before they're actually
accessed, and then we bring those
blocks into the cache ahead of time,
before they actually will be accessed.
So with no prefetching,
if time goes to time goes to the right,
we might have an access here.
Let's say load word A, and then we check
quickly whether it's in our cache,
and if it is not, we will go to memory
and spend a lot of time waiting for
it until it comes back, so here we
can supply the data to the processor.
So this is what happens
with no prefetching.
With prefetching, assuming that the load
would happen here, sometime before
the load, we have to guess that A will
be accessed and request it from memory.
Now, what was memory latency here,
will be here, and at this point,
the block is in the cache, so
when we try to load it, we have a hit.
As you can see, with prefetching, we
are guessing what will be accessed and
start fetching it from
memory into the cache.
If we guess correctly,
instead of a miss, we get a hit.
If we guessed incorrectly,
we brought something into the cache
that replaced something that
might have been useful.
So with prefetching we have, the good
guesses will eliminate misses, but
bad guesses lead to what is called
cache pollution because we are bringing
stuff that is useless into the cache.
If it doesn't get access, that means
that maybe it would never have been
brought to the cache in the first place.
And because of cache pollution,
because we kick out something that might
have been useful with useless data,
not only that we didn't
eliminate the miss here,
because we guessed wrongly,
we also might have created another
miss because we kicked out something
that later might be accessed.
And that we don't like.
So overall prefetching is about
trying to make good guesses so
that we eliminate misses while
trying to eliminate bad guesses
because we don't want to
create additional misses.